these mountain glaciers contain less
fresh water than originally thought
and that doesn't just mean a loss of
natural beauty
it puts the fresh water supply for
millions of people at risk it's easy to
just focus on the impacts of ice loss on
tourism because those of us in the
western will visit glacier systems as a
leisure activity but actually people who
live around them and actually downstream
from them more importantly depend upon
them as a buffer for the amount of water
that enters the river systems from which
they irrigate their crops and and drink
high resolution satellite images have
allowed scientists to more accurately
calculate how fast the glacier is moving
the faster it moves the thinner it is
and the less water it contains
that might mean the world's sea levels
might not rise by quite as much as
originally thought
what you have to keep in mind is that
our study does not include include the
green land and the antarctica ice sheet
who in the long term will be the major
drivers of sea level rise and just
looking at the the total volume of the
ice sheet compared to the glaciers if
all antarctica would melt
it has the potential to
increase the silver rice by more than 50
meters which is
way more than the 25 centimeters
from the glaciers
countries around the world are
struggling with disappearing glaciers
peru is investing in desalination to
make up for the loss of fresh water
and chile hopes to create artificial
glaciers in the andes
but that won't be enough we don't want
all the glaciers to melt we want them to
last as long as possible and the fact
that there's 20
less ice stored in mountain glaciers if
nothing else changes means that they'll
disappear 20 sooner we don't want to be
in a situation where there's no ice left
on earth we want to preserve the ice on
earth and that now overnight becomes a
more difficult challenge
a challenge those most affected hope the
world will accept
julian wolfe al jazeera